you
[Music]
faces are the most important subject
matter in art it's a never-ending source
of material when you put on one of my
masks you become somebody different you
start to embody that character and have
a lot of fun with it
my name is Landon Meyer and I make
disturbingly realistic masks I never
thought I was gonna make a living doing
masks when I was a picture framer loan
officer pizza delivery driver and then I
got laid off I've always been interested
in doing something that's like really
surreal and nightmarish so it was more
or less an experiment that took off I am
the only person out there that's doing
hyper-realistic lightness masks I'm kind
of this weird mad scientist
down in the basement I start off getting
lots of reference material the hardest
part is doing the sculpture that can
take anywhere from four days to a year
but once the sculpt is done and I have a
mold it's about a one week process to
make a mask
they are ungodly expensive they ranged
$500 and up and sometimes even high as
$7,500 over the years I've made
approximately 25 different designs and
I've produced with my own hands over a
thousand masks
what I make I like to consider wearable
art these are super realistic sculptures
you can put over your head and where
people just seem to have this astonished
reaction to the masks that's what I love
about them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as it radicchio move tower of two
viruses gone actually to do pooja one is
left for the bra will develop with
alacrity in the United to suppose a
bogus bogus cathedral detail and a space
go be punished cousins the suave lever
is some grad program focused to detail
it over Bulgaria culture every bit the
way that's private Naga Christopher
notable you know Bulgaria this govern
was it a Duke evasive and mrs. details
in her garments aunty people sitting
very promising to me as well the
prepositional brand recognition and
apricot with master grouper for him as a
cookies kiss with federal customer Sinha
prabh in your morale booster original
private the president tells the world of
his own volition national protein and
English juntos para process or glacial
Tunis Amato Javad McCoy - especially
with broader culture the soul clashes
the dosa question
[Music]
to vanish to demo pre-election Apaches
Cooney a Samata sir Watkyn optimal said
emotionless
it would be in the investor not
particularly in the best religiousness
Ravi no cigar poverty to nutritive of
kukuczka festival director so that no
damage to horizontal transmission was
sustained you know certain to know you
must respect first record on internal
emotional baggage amount
tamati motel boggling authority to
declare this crostini no co2 has a
curvature there's a stress no no not
amazed to see he divided it is devoid
awesomest go it was gulam moonda
voltages a producer
[Music]
for 31 years I have been acting in major
motion pictures in TV series but you may
not recognize my face I'm Doug Jones I
am an actor I got into acting out of a
need almost to be validated and it was
at Ball State University that I
discovered the art of mime it's a very
visual form of communication and
entertainment little did I know that
this would be early training ground for
the career that I was going to have lay
in later years I had no idea after
moving out to Hollywood land in March of
1985 and thinking okay now's the time to
pursue this acting thing my fourth
booking was for a McDonald's campaign
that got me kind of hooked into oh he's
that tall skinny guy who wears stuff and
moves well in it and doesn't complain
while doing so my first feature film was
Batman Returns I got that audition
because of my contorted legs and the
credits that says thin clown which kind
of kind of self descriptive isn't it I
have been in over 150 productions that
would include everything from feature
films like hocus pocus
Hellboy 1 Hellboy 2 the Golden Army the
fawn in Pan's Labyrinth was a page
turning a career moment for me
Fantastic Four rise of the Silver Surfer
I played the Silver Surfer Star Trek
discovery as commander slew and most
recently the shape of water so when
asked about how long is a makeup take it
depending on the creature it can be
anything from a suit going on and
zipping up the back or a makeup that is
applied you from head to toe for
instance as commander surreal and Star
Trek discovery it's around 2 hours a day
which is mercifully short flip-side
would be an Abe Sapien from the Hellboy
movies so that's one of the longer ones
that took seven hours a day wearing
rubber bits that gets everything that
you think it would be it is hot
you want to be it is heavier than you
want it to be it's more isolating than
you want it to be you can't always make
it access to your naughty bits to go pee
if you want why go through all of this
makeup application the time that it
takes you can create monsters with the
effects now I think people like to watch
other people so even if that person is
playing a monster they want to connect
with a human's interpretation and
performance of that monster it's
old-school cinema magic I kind of get
the best of both worlds when it comes to
being a public celebrity the bigger
movies I've been in and the bigger
things that I'm known for I look like
this and on the street
I'm just the tall skinny guy that's a
gift now that I'm in a movie like the
shape of water with 13 Oscar nominations
I'm getting recognized in public a
little bit more but it's still not to
the point where I where I have people
hiding in my bushes hoping to get a
snapshot at me topless that's not
happening again
[Music]
I think the typical censored looks nerdy
predominantly Caucasian so I think I'm
on the complete opposite spectrum of
what a fencer looks like acts like and
is in person
I'm Watson Watson I'm a two-time
Olympian and world champion as a trouble
9 after all I had to do a lot of
extracurricular activities I was offered
in my middle school so I first picked up
a foil which is what they I like to call
a sword I just immediately fell in love
with it I don't think we were taking
this far but I've been rowing with ever
since people should know that fencing is
it's a combat sport they think it's
super thoughtfully and all this but no
it's really intimate
you can literally hear them breathing
you can see their eyes and really see if
someone's scared if someone has no
emotions and that's so cool about the
sport is you can really gauge opponent
emotionally which I don't think you can
do many sports well I think the fencing
community they've embraced me but they
have people obviously who wanted to just
were the same people have always said
like you won't win this competition you
want make a national team you won't ever
you know they can look a team you know
you won't be well champion I'm gonna win
just you took Mickey here work energy
motivators this is comes with territory
the first time I have a qualify for
Olympics it's just the most incredible
feeling because all that hard work pays
off because 0.1% of the publication goes
to the Olympics I think being out there
just you have more Drive than everyone
else but you want to prove you wrong
[Music]